hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast utilizing same-day sepsis
pathogen ID for faster therapy enhance
stewardship and improved outcomes
presented by dr. Cornelius Clancy from
the university of pittsburgh i am xavier
tears of lab roots and i will be your
moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lab roots and
sponsored by t2 bio systems incorporated
for more information on our sponsor
please visit www.disabilitydenials.com
the support tab found at the top-right
of the presentation window or report
your problem by clicking on the answer
question box located on the far left of
your screen this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of the presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credits I'd like to now introduce
our presenter dr. Cornelius Clancy dr.
Clancy is the associate professor of
medicine in the infectious diseases
division and the director of the
mycology program at the university of
pittsburgh dr. Clancy is widely
published and a respected scientific
expert on novel Diagnostics
he is a leading researcher on men
antimicrobial resistance in bacteria and
fungi and their clinical relevance dr.
Clancy you may begin your presentation
my name is Cornelius Clancy from the
University of Pittsburgh I also go by
Neal Clancy and
today I'll be talking about t2 Nano
diagnostic panels for the diagnosis and
identification of pathogens causing
bloodstream infections so as you all
know bloodstream infections are
associated with significant morbidity
mortality and the time the
administration of appropriate anti
microbials is a crucial determinant of
outcome among patients so for example on
the right here data from Kevin Geary
showing outcomes and mortality among
patients with Candida bloodstream
infections and shown significant
increases in mortality rates among
patients for each day that the
initiation of appropriate antifungal
therapy is delayed and there are similar
data for bacterial bloodstream
infections blood cultures are considered
the diagnostic gold standard for
identifying bloodstream infections
parallel we know that these are limited
by suboptimal sensitivity sensitivity
ranging from 10% among patients with
suspected suspected bacteremia up to 50%
in patients with septic shock and we
know among patients with Candida
bloodstream infection so at Hema
consciously disseminated candidiasis
sensitivity is also 50% or less and
blood cultures are further limited by
slow turnaround time which delays the
institution in many instances of
appropriate antimicrobial therapy so the
insensitivity of blood culture presents
a challenge than both to clinicians
caring for patients and for new research
on novel diagnostic tests and then the
clinic the impact is obvious delays in
the institution of treatment contribute
to poor patient outcomes and conversely
the inability to accurate make accurate
and timely diagnosis promotes empiric
and pre-emptive antimicrobial usage and
with that of the development of n our
microbial resistance on the clinical
trial and the intensity of blood culture
presents a challenge for us in
interpreting what the meaning of
discordant new diagnostic tests positive
blood culture negative results really
mean are these patients who are false
positives on your new diagnostic tests
or are they true positives that are in
fact missed by the insensitive blood
culture and for this reason there has
been interest in looking at
posit microbiological clinical criteria
in clinical trials that assess the
performance of new diagnostics and we'll
get into this a bit more during the
presentation today so the United States
Food and Drug Administration in
September of 2014
cleared the t 2 DX instrument and the
teacher candidate panel for the direct
detection of Candida species within
whole blood samples from humans and
suspected invasive fungal infections in
fact this was the first FDA clearance of
a diagnostic direct from blood test for
the identification of blood-borne
pathogens and just last month in May of
2018 FDA cleared the t 2 bacteria panel
again using the teeth teacher DX
platform this time using whole blood
samples to detect five leading bacterial
causes of bloodstream infection and
today t 2 candidate t2 bacteria remain
the only done rest from blood
Diagnostics cleared by FDA
so both teacher candida and t2 bacteria
are automated rapid culture independent
systems and they run on this fully
automated instrument shown here in a
picture on the bottom a desktop
instrument you take a blood - 4 ml stop
it directly into the machine it'll
automatically rice cells amplify DNA
targets from the candida or bacteria of
interest it glomer rates the the
particles nanoparticles with your
amplified DNA and the detects and
identifies the pathogens by magnetic
resonance and hence the name t2 magnetic
resonance non-diagnostic
particles so the teacher candidate panel
has limits of detection for what we call
the big five Candida species at 3 CF use
per ml or less depending on species and
this will give them results reported in
one of three ways as positive for
Candida albicans or kantham tropicalis
candida glabrata or candida cruzi i or
positive for Candida prompts losses and
these pathogens account for 95% of more
of them basic and eyes
is at most centers and they also have
particular susceptibility patterns that
can allow you then to make rational
antifungal choices based on what the
anticipated susceptibility of the
different species were the t2 bacterio
panel as I mentioned identifies five
bacterial species and our caucus species
Staphylococcus aureus gram positive
bacteria and the gram-negative bacteria
of E coli Klebsiella pneumoniae and
Pseudomonas aeruginosa and these four
five species account for 50% or more of
bloodstream infections and the
sensitivity is comparable to that of the
teacher cam to the assay with density as
low as to colony forming units per ml
occult blood being detected so my
objectives today are are going to be to
review the performance of t2 Campbell
amt2 bacteria and diagnosing bloodstream
infections and to compare the
performance with that blood culture and
will pay particular attention to
patients who are receiving antimicrobial
agents at the time of testing secondly
I'll talk about the clinical
significance of these discordant t2
positive blood culture negative results
for both the candida and bacterial panel
and then finally I'll discuss strategies
for how we might rationally develop
patient management strategies that
incorporate these tests and bring them
into clinical practice so let me start
with with t2 can be done and then I'll
take a similar approach to t2 bacteria
in the second half of the presentation
so FDA clearance was based largely on
data from this multicenter clinical
trial the so-called direct one study
this is performed at 15 us centers
involved over 1,500 prospectively
collected blood samples which were
largely negative for any candidate
bacteria and in fact only six patients
enrolled in this pace she had a blood
culture that was positive but one of the
five came to the speech he said it's
detected by the teacher capita assay
there were also 250 contrived blood
samples that were spiked with various
concentrations of the five species that
are detected and with these samples the
sensitivity and specificity of t2
cavitation
on the bottom of the slide year we're 91
and 99% respectively and the turnaround
time for the test was 4 hours plus or
minus 1 hour compared to 5 plus or minus
1 days for blood culture so FDA cleared
the test based on these data but there
were two major questions that were left
unresolved at the conclusion of direct 1
and the first is since only 6 patients
actually had candy Mia in the original
direct 1 trial what is the clinical
sensitivity of the test in real-world
clinical experience and then a second
question is shown here on the bottom of
the data presented to the left where 29
or almost 2 percent of the patients in
the original direct 1 study in fact had
these discrepant T 2 Candida positive
blood culture negative results 29
patients and question is what is the
significance clinically all these
discrepant results so my objectives will
be to answer both of these questions and
to get at this first review data from
the direct to study which was published
recently in clinical infectious diseases
and this was a multicenter trial at 14
us Center it's most of whom participated
in direct one as well it involved adults
greater than 18 years of age and how
many Tracy study design patients were
enrolled at the time that a diagnostic
blood culture was reported as positive
for Candida and then at that point
patients were enrolled and two to three
days later after the diagnostic blood
culture came positive a follow-up T to
Candida and companion blood culture were
drawn simultaneously from the same
access site and the blood culture was
always collected immediately prior to
the teacher sample from the same site so
teacher candida and the so called
companion blood culture draw at the same
time where to find us positive if they
identify the candida species that was
identified in the corresponding
diagnostic blood culture that was
originally drawn and identified a canvas
species the primary end point was
teaching
at a clinical sensitivity which was
defined as the teacher can that a
positive being patients who had at the
same time a positive companion blood
culture the secondary endpoint was t2
candidate performance among the entire
cohort of patients who originally
identified by the positive diagnostic
blood culture and we included patients
who were both receiving and not
receiving anti-fungal agents at the time
of enrollment into the trial to mimic
clinical clinical practice and how the
tests would be used in the real world
and here are the results so after
exclusion 152 patients were enrolled as
shown here on the left and the median
time from collection of the original
diagnostic blood culture and then the
collection of the subsequent teacher
candidate a or companion blood culture
was 55 hours here we could see the
patient clinical characteristics and
demographics and simply to point out
that this was a typical patient
population that would be enrolled leak
and edenia trials and also to draw
attention to the fact that
three-quarters of these patients were in
fact receiving anti-fungal agents at the
time of enrollment in two studies so at
the time that the teacher sampling
companion blood culture were drawn they
were already on antifungal therapy
here's a breakdown at the Candida
microbiology
you can see on the pie chart here the
biggest slices are for Candida albicans
candida glabrata and canada propsal OSes
which were enrolled in equal numbers
there were a fewer fewer patients who
had Kim the tropicalis or current can
the crew see eye infections and then a
handful of mixed-species infections so
here's the primary endpoint which is the
t2 candida clinical sensitivity and it
was 89 percent among 36 patients who had
a companion blood culture that was
positive for one of the five species
detected by the t2 paddle in fact the t2
positive result identified the same
Candida species in 32 of those you'll
notice then that in four patients the
companion blood culture was positive
however the t2 sample simultaneously
collected was negative so can look at
the results among the entire cohort of
152 patients were enrolled based on
their diagnostic blood culture result t2
candida was positive in 45% of those
patients or 69 compared to companion
blood culture being positive in 24% of
those patients or 36 and in fact the
teacher candidate was significantly more
likely to be positive at the time for
Roman into the study then were comparing
blood cultures and interestingly enough
there was no difference whatsoever among
patients who are not receiving
antifungal therapy the positivity rate
would teach you candida and companion
blood cultures was approximately 30
percent in each however t2 Candida was
significantly more likely to be positive
than the companion blood culture among
the 75% of patients who are already
receiving antifungal therapy 50 percent
of t2 positive versus only 20% of the
companion blood culture is positive and
this was highly statistically
significant so if we break down the
combined t2 Candida in Campania blood
culture results we get this flowchart
again starting with the entire cohort of
152 patients if you just go to the
bottom row there you can see that
teacher candida and companion blood
cultures were simultaneously positive
both positive in 20% of patients on the
bottom right you see that both tests
were negative teacher negative companion
blood culture negative in just over 50%
of patients and then within the red box
you get the discrepant test results you
see the four patients are previously
mentioned to a teacher negative
companion blood culture positive
representing three percent of the entire
cohort and then 37 percent 37 patients
or 25% of the entire cohort in fact had
T to positive companion blood culture
negative results so we know these
patients were originally Kennedy make
from the diagnostic blood culture so t2
camden identified 37 patients who were
missed by the companion blood culture
compared to only for patients who are
identified by the campaign
blood culture and this by teaching
Canada and similar to what I just showed
you the strongest independent predictor
of a teacher positive blood culture
negative result was in fact the previous
receipt of anti-fungal so identifying
patients primarily those who are already
receiving and so that brings us then to
our next question what is the clinical
significance of these discordant results
and in particular these t2 positive
blood culture negative results and data
are now emerging to get at the
biological clinical significance of its
findings so the first study L site was
published recently in the Journal of
antimicrobial chemotherapy this was by
Patricia aminos and a consortium out of
Madrid several hospitals there who have
used t2 candidate in a couple of novel
ways so the first study they did was a
prospective observational study of
patients who are receiving definitive
antifungal therapy because they had a
positive blood culture and therefore had
positive proven candid emia and the
endpoint of this study was the
development of complicated Candida Mia
which they defined as attributable
mortality or the development of
metastatic deep-sea beacon biases as a
complication of bloodstream infection so
he didn't longitudinal testing with t2
with blood cultures and with serum beta
glucan in this study so within five days
of the original positive diagnostic
blood culture if you had a positive t2
result that was an independent risk
factor for the development of
complicated Cantigny and in fact the
odds ratio was 36 the sensitivity of a
teacher positive result within five days
for identifying patients who develop
complicated cam Gambia was 100% the
specificity was 76% and in this cohort
the positive and negative predictive
values for complicated key anemia or 64%
and 100 percent respectively
so I'll draw a particular attention to
the 100% negative predictive value it
meant if the teacher candidate test was
negative
none of these patients went on to
develop complicated can't be so very
much on mark
for good treatment response and good
outcome and in fact what culture or
serie beta glucan did not correlate or
without comes whatsoever so indicating
that there was clinical and biological
significance to the T to pick Candida
result that is not seen with the other
tests including so a I'm sorry I messed
up the slides are a little bit but a
second study then at the same consortium
in Madrid and again publisher the same
edition of the Journal of antimicrobial
chemotherapy by Patricia Munoz and her
colleagues
this was another prospective
observational study and what they did
here is rather than studying definitive
blood culture proven Kennedy Mia
they studied empirical antifungal
therapy among patients who are receiving
treatment for suspected but not
definitively diagnosed Canada
bloodstream infection and what they
found here is that a positive baseline
t2 after starting antifungal treatment
was an independent risk factor for the
subsequent development of either death
or crewman Kenneth Isis with an odds
ratio of 26 and again neither the serum
beta glucan or in this case candida
advocate albicans drug tube antibodies
correlated with outcome so claude
gnostic significance at the time of
initiation of empiric antifungal therapy
for poor outcomes among patients who
have t2 positive results again showing
that there is clinical relevance to t2
positivity so i'll show you some hard
data then locally at the University of
Pittsburgh getting at this question as
well so we wrote 32 patients from UPI C
at the University of Pittsburgh Medical
Center in the direct to trial and in
fact mortality of 30 days among these
patients was 19% so 632 patients died if
we break down then the mortality
outcomes among our patients of 30 days
by t2 candida and blood culture results
this is what we get so if patients were
positive by either the t2 candida or the
simultaneously collected companion blood
culture the mortality rate was 50%
if the teacher will pause if teacher
positive comparing a blood culture
negative results were obtained the
mortality rate was 33% if T to Camden
and negative to companion blood culture
positive discrepant events were obtained
mortality was 50% again if you look at
the group in whom both tests were
negative T to candida blood culture
negative results shown on the far right
of the graph their mortality in this
case was only 5 percent so if we look at
this another way if we take any patient
or at a positive T to Candida the
mortality rate was 40% compared to only
9% among those and it was negative a
strong 10 trend toward significance
there similarly if you look at patients
who are companion blood culture positive
mortality rate a 50% companion blood
culture negative mortality rate of only
12% again another strong trend but if we
consider the test together where either
both T 2 candida and blood cultural
positive or either test was positive the
mortality rate was 42 percent compared
to only 5 percent among patients in whom
both tests were negative and this in
fact was statistically significant so
similar to the data out of Spain our
experience indicates that T 2 positive
blood culture negative results do have
clinical relevance and do identify a
patient population that is more likely
to have bad outcomes and in patients in
whom both tests are negative so based on
this performance can we divide rational
patient management strategies that allow
us to incorporate T 2 Candida into the
treatment of our patients and in
thinking about this I think the best
approach is to consider patient
populations who are varying degrees of
risk for camp tinea and ask how the
tests might perform in those populations
and one thing that's nice about Camden D
me as we know from the literature there
are very well described patient risk
groups and we have a good sense of what
the pretest likelihood of Candida mean
in these various populations is from a
large body of clinical experience that's
been collected over several decades so
here's a table that presents that data
and so if you take any patient in whom a
blood culture is collected for any
indication whatsoever so this would
basically be the direct ones study
design the prevalence of candy Mia in
that cohort is only 0.4% however if you
then start talking about subgroups of
patients say who are admitted into the
ICU or hemodialysis patients with Lyme
infections the likelihood of candy me
and that setting goes up to 1% and then
from there you can define different
populations with increasing risk of
candy Mia
for example septic shock patients
patients with ECMO or left ventricular
assist devices hope to say a 10% pretest
likelihood among patients who fulfill
various prediction scores for the
development of count anemia such as the
mycosis study group prediction score
that Lewis Ostrovsky and other set
published on so if you sign them pretest
likelihood it's based on these patient
populations of characteristics and we
assume that the teacher candidate is
going to perform as suggested by the two
direct studies with sensitivity and
specificity of 90 and 98% we can
calculate what the anticipated positive
and negative predictive values in the
respective populations would be and what
we can see then is as the likelihood of
Kennedy Mia increases the positive
predictive values increase the negative
predictive values in all settings remain
very very high in fact even in your
highest prevalence group those who
fulfill a prediction score for Kennedy
Mia the negative predictive value is
still 99 percent so I'll point out in
the lowest risk screw your negative
predictive value is excellent greater
than 99.9 percent however this is a rule
in which you're essentially starting
with the negative predictive value of
99.6% so in fact the test doesn't really
add all that much to what you know
already going in to ordering the test on
the patients so it's less likely to have
value here than the patients who are at
higher risk of can email I'll also point
out on the table to the right here if
you assume that teaching Candida is it
going to perform quite as well as in the
direct studies but instead it's going to
form more like PCR assays and PCR
meta-analysis literature for candidiasis
which suggests sensitivity of
specificity
of PCR assays of approximately 90% and
90 percent respectively what you see
there then is you get the same pattern
where the positive predictive values
will increase or your positive
predictive value is that each pretest
likelihood are lower than they would be
if the performance is truly 90 and
ninety-eight percent respectively
however you'll also notice that the
difference in negative predictive values
among these patients is less striking so
the negative predictive value even if
the performance is 90% 90% sensitive in
stress a specific still works very very
well so how do we use this to manage
patients and the fact is we don't know
what the threshold likelihood of can be
me is that justifies a Pyrrhic or
pre-emptive antifungal therapy however
there's a large body of literature from
critical care populations from
bone-marrow transplant recipients that
suggests empiric antifungal therapy is
effective at preventing anti fungal
infections and a pretest likelihood of
about 15 to 30 percent so if we take
that as our cutoff for initiating
antifungal therapy it would suggest that
any diagnostic test is going to have the
greatest utility if it takes us from
below that likelihood to above that
likelihood while at the same time
maintaining excellent negative
predictive value so where would that
come into play and in fact if you go
back to our our table with in the red
blocks here you see those patient
populations at different levels of test
performance in whom you go from below
the positive predictive value as a
pretest likelihood to above it after
getting your test result and in each of
these instances the negative predictive
value is still excellent so within the
box is where you to anticipate teacher
candidate testing would have the
greatest utility so focus here on
patients with septic shock so I've got
it listed in the table here as a 3 to 3
percent prevalence or pretest likelihood
in fact the literature would suggest
candidate accounts for anywhere from
three to ten percent of septic shock so
with that it would suggest that septic
shock is within the fat part of the
utility curve 42 candida and is a
population whom the test man
a particular value so with that the
University of Pittsburgh what we did in
rolling T to camp about is we focus in
on medical intensive care unit on
patients who had septic shock with an
idea that we'd anticipate that three to
ten percent of those patients actually
had cavity and then with that will
exploit the positive predictive values
its tests are positive to initiate
antifungal therapy and patients with a
positive test result among patients who
are already started on antifungal
therapy conversely will use the
excellent negative predictive values in
conjunction with blood cultures to
discontinue antifungal therapy of
patients who or at low risk of actually
having candidate so this has been rolled
out in or maybe you through a diagnostic
stewardship team that is led by our
antimicrobial stewardship director at
UPMC long win and here are the
preliminary results for the first
seventy for patients who are run through
the pilot program in our medical
intensive care unit and on the left
there what you can see in the 2x2 table
is that eight percent of patients who
fulfilled entry criteria for septic
shock in the Mikio in fact had a
positive blood culture for Candida
exactly within my three to ten percent
range that we anticipated going into the
into the pilot study going across that
table you'll see that T two positive
results were obtained in 12 of those
patients and if you look at the Venn
diagram the middle e below the table you
see that we had six patients in whom
teacher was positive both call short- we
had three patients in whom the blood
culture was positive but teacher was
negative and then we had another three
patients in room both tests were
positive so if he added up together we
had discordant T two positive blood
culture results in 12 percent of
patients either teacher was positive
with a negative blood culture or teacher
was negative on the blood culture was
positive and then if you look at
patients who either had a positive blood
culture or a positive T - that was 16
percent of patients so remember we said
that 8 percent of patients had positive
blood cultures we anticipate the blood
cultures are only going to be about 50
percent sensitive so therefore 16
percent is spot on what we
anticipated if teacher was working the
way we would hope so encouraging results
so the overall sensitivity shown to the
right there was 50% three out of six a
bit lower than the clinical trial it's a
small number of patients another thing
that we noticed is that in the real
world blood cultures will often not be
drunk the same time in the t2 test which
confounds the interpretation of this
results to some extent in three patients
the teacher result was available before
the blood culture and patients are
started on appropriate antifungal
therapies earlier they would have been
by relying on blood culture the
specificity in our early experience was
91% but that assumes that those t2
positive blood culture negative results
are false positive from basic analysis
if you drill down low and you look at
the patient level data in two of those
patients they in fact had an
intra-abdominal infection it was not
drained but it's entirely plausible that
these patients had a trip Dominic
antibiotics Asst and then into other
patients there was not a definitive
etiology of sepsis that was identified
however patients did respond to
antifungal therapy so if you consider
these four patients as possibly having
had undiagnosed candidiasis the
adjustment specificity of the test would
have been 97% and here's our antifungal
usage in the unit before and after we
instituted taeju testing and what you
can see is that we had significant
reductions in overall antifungal usage
for both fluconazole and Kasper Fondren
and attended to reductions of almost 50%
in antifungal expenditures the duration
of therapy pre and post intervention was
a cut almost in half so with that now
we've developed other unit based
strategies in different units with
different patient populations and we're
rolling these out one by one at UPMC
taking advantage of both positive and
negative predictive values in the
appropriate settings to either initiate
or deescalate antifungal therapy for
example here's an algorithm for our
surgical intensive care units here we're
going to have an awful lot of patients
who are at risk for abdominal
candidiasis
so the model and paradigm
a bit different than for Kennedy Mia but
just to show that you can tailor use of
the test and interpretation results and
the attended management strategies based
on the specific types of patients and
the specific risk they have for
candidiasis so one size does not fit all
but unit based strategy is what we've
employed on the benefit that we've seen
in our pilot studies has been recorded
elsewhere so here's another example
published recently in the Journal of
antimicrobial chemotherapy this was a
hospital Syria healthcare system series
Ospital in the southern United States
that instituted t2 camped at a testing
they did a retrospective study of their
patients with candid emia and after
history can't teach you can too that
they had significant reductions in mean
time to appropriate antifungal therapy
among patients with positive results six
verses thirty four hours prior to the
introduction of detail and well over the
mean duration of empirical antifungal
therapy among people who were
subsequently identified as not having
invasive can diocese was significantly
shortened with T 2 from 2 days in
patients who have T to negative blood
culture negative results versus 6 days
prior to the institution of T 2 testing
and overall the estimated antifungal
savings in this study were approximately
$50,000 which worked out to an average
of two hundred eighty dollars per
patient tested so with that I think it's
fair to say that teaching Candida is an
advance in the diagnosis of Cara Mia it
can accurately diagnose Kennedy Mia at
the time of positive blood cultures and
they may identify at least some of the
cases that we know we're missing usually
blood cultures alone and this includes
most importantly patients who are
already receiving pre-emptive or empiric
antifungal therapy it has advantages a
rapid turnaround time however we know
there will be use best in conjunction
with blood cultures Brad lettuce or a
placement for blood cultures and it's
imperative that you understand your
local epidemiology if you're at a center
that sees a large number of Candida
species other than the big five then
test performance may differ than at
centers that are seen almost exclusively
with the clock can be the species
we know that increasing evidence
indicates now that combined T to candida
and blood culture results can predict
poor outcomes of Candida Mia and
something for future studies to look at
is is that these data suggest it may be
possible to identify low risk patients
in whom short course antifungal therapy
is possible so if patients have T to
negative blood culture negative results
after starting antifungal therapy this
might be in cohort in whom we don't need
to give a full two week or longer course
of treatment
antifungal treatment de-escalation
strategies and incorporate incorporate T
two results can shorten time to
initiation of antifungal therapy and can
reduce overall antifungal usage I think
major questions right now that will be
answered as more clinical experience
accrues is can we use these management
strategies not only to reduce antifungal
usage or shorten the content that humble
therapy or can we actually impact
patient outcomes and improve outcomes
there are questions that will be
answered about what the performance in
deep tissue candidiasis and other non
bloodstream forms of disease such as
intra-abdominal candidiasis and the we
ongoing economic analyses to understand
the cost effectiveness as well suggested
in the recent jhc slide so with that let
me we'll want to teach you bacteria and
I'll basically take the same approach
and running through the T 2 bacterial
data I'll conclude that by talking about
some of our thoughts locally about how
it might use this test so FDA clearance
last month was based largely on data
from the pivotal trial he represented at
at ahmed and recently at ASM micro this
was a prospective study performed at 11
us centers the principal investigators
were left eros and Milonakis
from Brown University at home when my
colleague here from the University of
Pittsburgh
again a study of adults these are
patients in whom a diagnostic blood
culture was ordered per standard of care
and a design in which the blood culture
was simultaneously collected along with
the whole blood sample 42 collected for
teaching
so just to run through some definitions
here a proven bloodstream infection was
defined as patients who had a positive
blood culture but recognizing that blood
culture is going to miss its significant
number of truly infected patients
definitions of probable impossible
disease were also assigned so probable
disease was a patient into him the taeju
bacterial result was positive but the
blood culture was negative however a
positive culture either from the blood
at a different time of collection or
from an extra blood site within 15 days
of study enrolled linked along with
clinical signs and symptoms of infection
was taken to indicate probable
bloodstream infection possible
bloodstream infection was defined as a
t2 positive blood culture negative
results again associated with a syndrome
that clinically seemed consistent with
infection but in this case cultures were
either not performed or were negative
for one of the five bacterial species
identified by the t2 asset so almost
1,500 paired samples from unique
patients were collected overall six
percent or eighty two of the blood
cultures were positive for one of the
five species detected by the asset we're
positive of these about half were
positive from for one of the five
species detected by the assets of 39
patients if we look at the organisms
that were recovered from blood culture
showing the the 50% that were detected
that were the target organisms staph
aureus and e-coli in 20 and 11%
respectively and then Klebsiella
pneumoniae Pseudomonas aeruginosa and
Enterococcus CCO the mean time to both
blood culture positivity was 51 plus or
minus 43 hours the mean time to blood
culture species identification was 84
hours plus of minus 47 hours compared to
mean time to t2 bacterial results
including species identification of 5.4
plus of is 1.6 hours so significantly
shorter time to diagnosis if you look at
the primary endpoint sensitivity of the
T to bacterial assay again I mentioned
39 patients for blood culture positive
for the T to bacteria targets all of
these the teacher bacteria test in fact
was positive simultaneously in 35 so
giving you an overall sensitivity of 90%
in four patients the blood culture was
positive while the teacher bacteria was
negative and if we look at the breakdown
then of sensitivity by target organism
we see 100% for Enterococcus faecium
Klebsiella pneumoniae and Pseudomonas
90% and eighty-one percent respectively
or ecoli at staph aureus and the
attendant confidence intervals are
indicated there there are archive tubes
that were available for patients in whom
ecoli or staph aureus was not originally
detected and among four samples that
were available for repeat testing on the
archived sample in fact the Ecola that
was originally negative in the archived
sample was detected by t2 bacteria and
one of the three staph aureus was
detected upon testing the archived
sample as well so if we look at
antibiotic usage on the day that
patients were tested for those who had a
paired t2 positive blood culture
negative result
the results are broken down by species
here but to summarize them but on the
day of sample collection only 1/3 of
patients in whom teach you and blood
culture work both positive were
receiving an active agent against the
bacteria doctor test was possible or so
stated another way two-thirds of the
patients might theoretically have
benefited by having the t2 a positive
result available prior to cultures and
initiated appropriate antibiotic therapy
earlier as a result of having had back
Esau
so here's a look at the entire cohort
toward the left the sensitivity that I
mentioned of 90% the 35 out of 39
patient's detected by teacher bacteria
on the right you can see the large group
of patients in whom blood cultures were
negative and here are calculating the
specificity if we use blood culture as
the gold standard for specificity the t2
bacterio specificity was calculated at
89% or 1233 patients out of 1388 so
that's with proven blood stream
infection using blood culture it's the
gold standard however if you looked at
patients who had probable or possible
bloodstream infections in this graph
what we can see is that false positivity
is decreased in these groups so on the
far left there in the green bar 11% lost
positivity rate if you use gold standard
blood culture is gold standard 89%
specificity specificity increasing to
94% however if you use probable
bloodstream infection as the comparator
in this in the salmon colored bar and on
the far left for all patients in the
blue bar specificity of 96% if you
consider either probable or possible
bloodstream infections as the comparator
and then the breakdown by individual
species shown similar results at the
teaching calculus of teaching bacterial
species level so if we use our
definitions then among patients who have
discordant t2 bacterial positive blood
culture negative results we see about
30% of these patients in fact fulfilled
definition for probable bloodstream
infection another 23% fulfill the
definition of possible bloodstream
infection so altogether about 36% of
patients had t2 positive results for
which we had no indication of ongoing
infection and presumably this is your
false positive cohort and interestingly
enough over half the patients would
discordant t2 bacterium
positive blood culture negative results
we're receiving antibiotics
attesting that were active against the
bacteria that was identified so similar
to the theme with the teacher candidate
with the tests performed particularly
well among patients who will receive an
antimicrobial so how might we use this
test and in clinical practice and we
flowed a lot about this University of
Pittsburgh and to do it I think you need
to understand what's happening with
bloodstream infections that you're at
your institution so we reviewed
bloodstream infection microbiology at
UPMC in calendar year 2017 and it's
reflected in these pie charts so we can
see on the left the breakdown by gram
positive organisms accounting for the
majority of our bloodstream infections
over twenty three hundred nine hundred
fifty gram negative in that smaller
number of fungal or anaerobic affections
and on the right on the top you have the
gram positive organisms on the bottom
you have a gram negative organisms so
simply to point out that the predominant
gram positive organism is staph aureus
followed by Co AG negative staph and
that the in our caucus species on the
bottom ecoli Klebsiella Pseudomonas the
big three detected by the teacher
bacterial panel account for the majority
of gram-negative bloodstream infections
at our institution so summarizing the
results at our Center 52% of all
bloodstream bacteria are on the t2
bacterial panel this represents just
under a half for the gram positives I
ever keep in mind that we have a large
body of patients who were infected or
who had positive cultures for collab
negative staph and in fact a large
percentage of these are going to be
contaminants so if you exclude going
negative staph we got about 67% of the
gram positive infections between staph
aureus and in our caucus on the panel
and we identified 63% of the gram
negative bloodstream infections so what
a gram-negative bloodstream infections
happening at the University of
Pittsburgh and in fact what we find is
that almost 50% of gram-negative
bloodstream infections are diagnosed
Media presentation at the hospital so
this is either in the emergency room or
upon first presentation to the medical
floor or to the ICU and moreover if you
look on the graph here days from mission
if you add the patients upon admission
times zero and the patients who are
positive within their first hospital day
in fact this accounts for the majority
of bloodstream infections moreover at
our Center 71 percent of the early
presenting gram-negative infections are
due to the species that are that are
available on the t2 bacterio path so how
are we treating bloodstream infection
empirically so if we look at our empiric
treatment what we find is that the
biggest single agent used among patients
who ultimately identified to have
bloodstream infection is cefepime
followed by is a ribosome phase about
cam I'm sorry followed by seperti and
then the carbapenems are third so for
the most part people have Pyrrhic we are
getting broad-spectrum Pseudomonas
active gram-negative agents 60% of
patients then are also administered
vancomycin empirically and if we
actually then look at how we're doing
with order of choices in fact we're not
covering the pathogen that's ultimately
identified in about 20 to 25 percent of
patients so we're using big gun
antibiotics and about a quarter of the
time even with that we're missing the
pathogen that's ultimately identified so
I'll review some data that have been
published in journal ground microbial
therapy and these are the first clinical
data published using t2 bacteria in a
real-world setting
these are data out of roll and what they
focused on our emergency departments and
intensive care units and what they found
in their experience in the Italian study
is sensitivity and specificity of T to
bacteria of eighty three percent at
eighty and ninety eight percent
respectively
using blood culture as your gold
standard however if
they use clinical indication of
infection similar to what we did with
probable a possible infection in the
pivotal study the sensitivity and
specificity improved to 89 and 98
percent so virtually identical to what
was seen in the pivotal study and again
t-to positive blood culture negative
results significantly more likely in
that large cohort of patients who have
already been started on antibacterial
agents so with the Italian data and with
how bloodstream infections occur at the
University of Pittsburgh
how might t2 bacteria actually help at
our Center and the first thing similar
to what we showed with teacher candidate
is the testing our best if implemented
through diagnostic management
stewardship teams and incorporated to
formalize patient management strategies
and our initial target is going to be
emergency room patients and those newly
admitted patients within the first 24
hours of evidence of sepsis in whom the
T to bacterial panel coverage looks
promising our Center and who account for
the majority of all bloodstream
infections that ultimately will be
diagnosed in ourselves and with that we
do not to think of what algorithms we
might use to incorporate the results so
and and these are works in progress
we're in the process of rolling these
out but for example if you identified an
e coli based on your t2 test and you had
a low-risk patient who is unlikely to
have extensively resistant we coli an
agent like ceftriaxone rather than the
17 or paisa that we're using in most
patients would be appropriate on the
other hand particularly among transplant
recipients at UPMC we have we have
significant rates of ES BLS and in this
setting if you have that type of patient
profile you could use this early result
perhaps to stratify to a carbapenem and
I won't go through this but it shows how
you can use your local data an early
pathogen identification to guide more
rational antimicrobial choices
I'll also point out if you start getting
negative results for staph aureus or or
enter caucus for
example you might be able to stop that
go early and like I said we know that
60% of our patients aren't purely
getting back out so you can use positive
and negative results based on your local
epidemiology to come up with more
rational empiric and then ultimately
definitive antimicrobial matching
strategies I think the the evidence from
both teaching cam to that mt2 bacteria
however as shown on the right here would
indicate that if you've got to teach you
a positive result in a blood culture
negative result and there's some
clinical indication of infection then
the best course of action we believe is
to go ahead and treat based on the
teacher Canada or the t2 bacterio result
in the likelihood that you'll identify
at least some patients who have false
negative blood cultures so in conclusion
teacher bacteria demonstrates excellent
performance in detecting bloodstream
infections due to the five species on
the teacher bacterial panel overall
sensitivity is ninety percent for the
five bacteria that account for greater
than 50 greater than or equal to 50
percent of bloodstream infections as
we're teaching Canada that's going to
work best in conjunction with blood
culture results specificities
approximately 90 percent if you use
blood cultures comparator but in fact
may be in the upper nineties if you
consider patients who have clinical
signs of infection despite negative
blood cultures the potential advantages
for teacher bacteria as 42 Canada our
turnaround time and the fact that you
were diagnosed at least some infections
that are missing out by blood culture
and in particular you're going to have
superior performance among patients who
are already receiving antimicrobial
agents so I think the clinical trial
data from both candida and bacteria
highlight the challenges newsy blood
culture is a gold standard in fact we're
teaching bacteria we found those
clinical evidence of infection at 64
percent of patients who had T to
bacterial positive blood culture
negative results and that in 55 percent
of patients and anestine antibiotics are
active against the bacteria that was
identified were being administered
so I'll answer questions 42 bacteria do
teach you about your cause and results
have prognostic significance if so how
can we use these and better treating our
patients or what are the kinetics of
teacher bacteria treated patients one of
the significance of serial test results
and can we identify low-risk patients
perhaps those who turn t to negative
rapidly in whom we could get away with
short course treatment Raburn for
treatment courses and i think the most
important slide is if you're going to
optimize utility of t2 candidate or t2
bacteria at your center you've got to
understand the microbiology and
epidemiology of invasive candidiasis of
bacterial bloodstream infections at your
Center and you've got to use the test
judiciously it's specific patient
populations with predetermined
objectives in mind and with that
conclude I just want to acknowledge our
team at the University of Pittsburgh a
home win is the director of our
stewardship and and diagnostic -
matine's and here's the diagnostic
stewardship team to give a particular
shout out to riot shields Rachel Marini
and Bonifacio known for these who
implemented testing on the grab in our
various intensive care units and with
that I'll be happy to answer any
questions thank you thank you dr. Clancy
for your informative presentation we
will now start the live Q&A portion of
the webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the answer your question box located
on the far left of your screen and we'll
answer as many questions as we have time
for let's get started
our first question is what patient
selection criteria should hospitals use
for these tests so young Xavier I think
the approach you have to take with both
t - Candida and T - bacteria is using
the test in some patient population whom
there's a reasonable probability that
infection by the pathogens that the test
is going to detect is present so for
Candida
I don't think this test has utility and
every page
blood cultures collected because neither
positive nor negative predictive value
in that setting it's really going to
help you but I think once you start
getting into your patients in the
intensive care unit with risk factors
for Candida Mia which after about 72
hours in the intensive care unit most
patients are going to have can't believe
it risk factors for patients in septic
shock I think are of crime targets for
utility and patients known both positive
and negative test results can help you I
think another large patient population
that I really need get into and this in
this presentation although I did allude
to it when I make reference to our
social intensive care unit paradigm that
we put together our patients with
abdominal disease in whom there's
suspicion of intra-abdominal campus it's
either peritonitis or abscesses that may
be complicated by bloodstream infection
as well so on the candida and I think
those are prime populations but again
you've got to know what kind of patients
are seeing at your center and you know
figure out how to test my best work for
your particular patient populations on
the bacterial side I think the Italian
experience and our experience suggest
that patients particularly those with
signs of sepsis immediately upon
presentation to the emergency room of
those who've been admitted say within
the first several hours of
hospitalization at least an hour center
those are going to account for the
majority of bloodstream infections that
you actually diagnose those are patients
in whom to make an empiric anti
antibiotic choices in most patients here
using broad-spectrum oftentimes multiple
agents and they are likely to be
infected with the gram negatives that
are on the panel as well as staph aureus
those are populations that I think the
tests would have have real utility
that's where we're first going to roll
out the bacterial panel at UPMC the
other population I didn't get into that
I think the test would also have very
very good utility is in something like
febrile neutropenia or again a big 3
gram negatives are gonna account for 75%
or more gram-negative infections that
are diagnosed we know that the vast
majority of patients febrile neutropenia
you never did
a bacterial pathogen suggesting that a
number of these are being missed by
blood cultures and a setting in which
empiric broad-spectrum and microbial
choices are being made so the ability to
identify a rule-out staff the ability to
identify things like e.coli Klebsiella
Pseudomonas that may have difficult
resistance panels these can be quite
useful at particular centers in
identifying patients in garden therapy
in the febrile neutropenia 7 so at least
the UPMC those are the two scenarios
were initially focusing on but again
it's knowing what you have in your
center where are these bacterias showing
off one of the resistance patterns and
where can we direct the test to get
maximal utility both with positive and
negative test results all right
bacterial culture grows faster than
fungal is there a clinical impact to
using the T to bacterial panel compared
to blood culture and what is the benefit
of ID only well I think clearly I mean
it's what the question is getting at is
the fact that you know the window
between say a culture turning positive
and a t2 positive result is going to be
a bit smaller with bacteria than it will
be with kantha Candida growing a bit
more slowly than bacteria well we know
in the sepsis setting in the blood
stream infection setting with bacterial
infections literally every hour makes a
difference in outcome
so even shortening from 24 to 36 hours
down to to 4 hours at least potentially
makes a major would have a major impact
on on outcome with bacterial infections
I think you can do the infections the
the impact of time is going to be even
greater
not uncommonly for something like Canada
crops the doses for example you might be
five days or more before a blood culture
trans positive so getting resulted in
five hours versus waiting two to three
days or in some cases five or more days
for camping identification I think you
know has potentially very important
impact and again for both these things
hours can make a difference for both
Canada and bacteria
any window that you close potentially
has real impact excellence there is a
higher positivity rate with t2 tests is
the system too sensitive or is it truly
better detection well I think you know
with the Candida data that we have so
far and I think the t2 bacterial data
will will show similar things once more
it accumulates is that t2 positive blood
culture negative results in at least
some instances have real biological and
prognostic significance and I think all
identifying the large body of patients
who we know we're missing my blood
cultures if you're using the test
traditionally in patients who have a
reasonable pretest likelihood of one of
these infections then the positive
predictive values are such that it's
worth treating these patients and I
think that's true for both t2 candida
and will will be proven to be true for
TQ bacteria
moreover the benefit appears to be
particularly in those patients who are
receiving antimicrobial therapy so what
means in the real world is I can start
my antifungal I can start my
antibacterial agent and even if the
blood draw doesn't get done prior to
starting the antimicrobial I can still
get value from the test result and those
are precisely the people in whom you
will not recover viable bacteria from a
blood culture because the anomaly is
inhibiting the growth of the bacteria so
you know III think teaching candidate e
to bacteria in that setting and give me
the importance of time to initiation of
active antimicrobial therapy I think
that'll be a particularly valuable use
of these tests as we accumulate more
experience with management strategies
based on the tests again we have time
for one last question
can you describe your experience
implementing and rolling out the tests
across a hospital or Health System right
Savior I think what places are going to
have
do is what I don't think is going to
work is rolling it out willy-nilly
across a hospital or across a healthcare
system I think time spent up front
trying to consider the patient
populations who are developing these
types of infections and what the
antimicrobial usage and resistance in
those particular populations is I think
upfront that'll be time well spent
because you'll get your biggest bang for
the test by using the test judiciously
in those patient populations so again
based on what we see we candidiasis at
the University of Pittsburgh we felt the
best place to roll it out initially was
with septic shock in our intensive care
units and then from there we've moved on
to the surgical intensive care units the
high risk abdominal patients I didn't
show it in the slide but the other
populations now we're going to move out
to our are complicated cardiothoracic
ECMO left ventricular assist device
patients and our liver transplant cohort
on the bacterial and as I said based on
what we see in our epidemiology and our
resistance patterns we think the
emergency room and early admitted
patients to the floor or to the units
with evidence of sepsis or where we'll
get the best utility with t2 bacteria so
I think these patient population
hospital and unit specific approaches or
where the test has has real real utility
and targeted introduction of the test
rather than you know system-wide roll
out is probably going to be most
effective I'd like to thank you again
dr. Clancy do you have any final
comments for our audience no I would
just encourage people who are
contemplating use of the class to
contact centers that have made use of it
and I would also say to places that are
using it it's actually imperative that
centers report their own experience
because in the end as a community this
is how we're going to learn there have
been three large multicenter studies to
with Candida to of bacteria I think now
we know what the test performance is in
terms of sensitivity specificity in the
clinical trial
setting what we need are real-world
clinical data and most importantly we
need management strategies that show
utility of the test in terms of guiding
antimicrobial therapy and ultimately
most important in terms of improving
patient outcomes
so report your experience as you use the
test excellent before we go I'd like to
thank the audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information provided at
the time of registration we would like
to thank lab roots and our sponsor t2
bio systems incorporated or underwriting
today's educational webcast this webcast
can be viewed on-demand through December
2018 laboratoire you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time goodbye